ouais c'est les petits projecteurs qui
nous enjoint la chanson
la trouvais plutôt jolie lily l arrivée
les somalie il dit
dans un bateau plein d'émigrés qui
venaient tous de leur plein gré vider
les poubelles à paris elle croyait qu'on
était goulili au pays de voltaire et
d'hugo midi mais pour debussy en
revanche il faut de noir pour une
blanche ça fait un sacré distinguo elle
aimait tant la liberté
elle rêvait de fraternité billy un
hôtelier rue secrétan lui a précisé
allard yvan qu'on ne recevait que des
blancs elle a déchargé les cageots ligny
elle s'est apaisée sale boulot lily
elle crie pour vendre les choux fleurs
dans la rue ses frères de couleur
l'accompagnent omar topic
et quand on l'appelait blanche-neige
lily elle se laissait plus prendre au
piège lily elle trouvait ça très amusant
même s'il fallait serrer les dents il
aurait été trop content
elle est moins beau blond frisé lilly
qui n est tout prêt à l'épouser
mais la belle famille dit nous ne sommes
pas racistes pour deux sous mais on veut
pas de ça chez nous elle a essayé la
mairie midi ce grand pays démocrates et
lily elle aurait pas cru sans le voit de
la couleur du désespoir
là bas aussi ce fut le noie met dans un
meeting à memphis lilly
et la vue angela davis lilly qui lui dit
viens ma petite soeur en s'unissant la
moins peur des loups qui guette le
trappeur et c'est pour conjurer sa pub
l'idée qu'elle lève aussi un point
au milieu de tous ces gugusses qui
foutent le feu aux autobus
un père dit aux gens de couleurs et dans
ton combat quotidien elie
tu connaîtras un type bien lilly et
l'enfant qui naît un jour aura la
couleur de l'amour contre laquelle on ne
peut rien
on l'a trouvé plutôt jolie lily l
arrivée les somalie liddy dans un bateau
plein dénigrer qui venaient tous de leur
plein gré vider les poubelles paris